-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
Hi.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys,
after months of speculation,
Joe Biden finally
made the announcement
we've all been waiting for.
-We're coming on the air
with breaking news.
Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden
has made his choice.
NBC News has confirmed
that Biden has picked
California Senator Kamala Harris
to be his running mate,
the first woman of color
in history to be chosen
for such a position.
-That's right,
Joe Biden has selected
Senator Kamala Harris
as his running mate.
Kamala is the daughter
of two immigrants,
she went to Howard University,
she's a Democratic senator
from California.
It's an inspiring story,
unless you're Trump.
Then it's a Stephen King novel.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in a statement,
Kamala said,
"I'm very much looking forward
to serving as President --
Vice -- Vice President!
I mean, Vice President."
Biden announced his selection
in a tweet and called Kamala
"a fearless fighter
for the little guy."
And Dr. Fauci was like,
"Thank you."
[ Laughter ]
She's only had the job
for a few hours,
but Kamala's already gearing up
for her debate with Mike Pence.
That's why she spent
the entire day
arguing with a mannequin
at Kohl's.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Kamala Harris
has been chosen by Joe Biden
as his running mate
and potential vice president.
Biden was quick to hold
a virtual press conference
to discuss his decision,
and people were very excited
to talk about it.
Take a look.
-Hey, folks,
thanks four for joining me
on your Zoom boxes.
I'm sure you're all
buzzing like a honey pot
to talk about Kamala.
You know, I'm thrilled to
announce her as my running mate
and can't wait
for all the excitement
and experience
she brings to the team.
But before I --
-Mr. Vice President,
what are Kamala's
plans for the country
once she gets
into the White House?
-Well, uh...
Kamala and I will work together,
hand in hand, in the White House
to restore
the soul of this nation.
-Mr. Vice President,
how does it feel
to be reaching this exciting
moment in your campaign?
Kamala Harris, wow.
-Well, you know, I thought
we were running a pretty
exciting campaign before this,
but --
-That's all.
-Okay.
-Excuse me, Mr. Biden?
I have a foreign-policy
question.
-Yeah, now we're talkin'.
-Has Kamala asked about me?
-Asked about you?
No.
How is that
a foreign-policy question?
-Oh, I was just hoping
to take a trip with her.
-All right, come on.
-Vice President Biden,
when you are the president...
-Thank you.
-...I think Kamala Harris
is amazing and inspiring.
-Is that a question?
-I think Kamala Harris
is amazing and inspiring?
-Okay.
-Is Kamala nice in person?
-Geez.
Yes, she's very, very nice.
-Knew it.
You can just tell.
Very kind eyes.
-I have a question, mister --
mister...
Oh, my God.
What was your name again?
-Joe Biden.
-Of course -- Jim.
My question is, is Kamala here?
-No, she's not.
-Aww!
-But I can send a link to her
virtual speech in the chat.
-Yay!
-All right.
Does anyone have a question
that is not about Kamala Harris?
-I do.
-Great. Shoot.
-How is Barack Obama doing?
-Seriously?
-And follow-up question --
Do you think you would ever
want to be
the Vice President again?
Maybe, like, next?
-Okay, th-th-that's enough.
I'm excited to have Kamala
running beside me
in this campaign,
and we will work together,
with me as the president
and Kamala Harris
as the vice president.
And that's how
it's going to go, okay?
Okay.
-Madam President!
Madam President!
-I -- I think you're confused,
Jack.
-No, I'm just practicing.
-But -- It's --
This is -- I know people
are excited about Kamala.
-Yay!
-Biden.
Kamala.
-Yay!
-All right, heck, I'm almost
taking this personal here.
Listen, at the end of the day,
I suppose old Joe
should take it as a compliment.
I believe in this woman,
even if she handed me my rear
at the debates.
And together,
we can accomplish anything.
Thank you all for coming.
I do have to go.
I am late
for another engagement.
Thank you all for coming.
[ Clicking ]
How do you get off this thing?
[ Clicking continues ]
Ah, hell.
-Well, that was interesting.
Well, guys,
here's some big news.
It was announced today that
there's a new vaccine
to treat the coronavirus.
Sort of.
-Breaking news this morning --
Vladimir Putin claiming
Russia has developed
and approved
the world's first
coronavirus vaccine,
a claim that is being met
with heavy skepticism,
despite Putin announcing
his own daughter
is among the first
to receive a dose.
-That's right.
Russia now claims
to have a coronavirus vaccine,
which is great.
'Cause if there's one thing
I know about Russia,
they never lie about drug tests.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no.
Vladimir Putin
defended the new vaccine.
He was like, "Don't worry.
Just like upcoming
U.S. election,
results are totally legitimate.
[ Laughs ]
That's right,
the new COVID vaccine
has been approved by four
out of five Russian scientists.
And in a related story,
one out of five Russian
scientists are now missing.
[ Laughter ]
-"What did you say?"
That's right --
over the course
of just under two months,
the vaccine was tested
on a couple dozen people,
some even willingly.
[ Laughter ]
Just to prove it safe, Putin
said that one of his daughters
actually got the vaccine.
I don't know
much about his family,
but I know that that kid
is definitely his "Don Jr."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe the vaccine will work.
So far,
the only side effects are
depression, hunger, and chills.
Although, in Putin's defense,
that's how everyone walked in
before the vaccine, so...
[ Laughter ]
In his announcement,
Putin said, quote,
"It works effectively enough."
[ Laughter ]
That's like your doctor saying,
"I got most of the ringworm.
Yeah, well --
we'll be fine."
When asked about the vaccine,
the U.S. Secretary
of Health and Human Services
said, "The point is
not to be first."
And Trump was like,
"Yeah, yeah, great.
A vaccine on my desk by lunch
or you're fired."
Speaking of the President,
last night, at the White House,
he tried to talk about
the 1918 pandemic,
and he was
a little off on his history.
Watch this.
-The closest thing is, in 1917,
they say -- right? --
the great -- the great pandemic
certainly was a terrible thing.
Probably ended
the second World War.
All the soldiers were sick.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw, come on.
-Not too bad.
He was only off by two decades.
What's the big deal?
What, what, what?
"Congratulations.
It's a baby boy.
And he can vote."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's basically like
the baseball coach
who subs in when
the history teacher gets sick.
[ Laughter ]
"All right,
World War II is, uh..."
Let's just put on a movie.
You guys like "Sandlot"?
[ Laughter ]
But Trump was like, "Those who
cannot remember the past
are condemned to retweet it."
At this point,
Trump's teleprompter
is just a shrug emoji.
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump said,
"And I believe the war ended
when President Truman uttered
his famous words,
'It is what it is.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Meanwhile,
Trump is thinking about a move
that would affect Americans
who traveled abroad.
Check this out.
-The Trump administration
is now reportedly considering
a new rule that could block
American citizens
and permanent residents
from returning to the country
if they are suspected
of having coronavirus.
-That's like if Pinterest said,
"Sorry. No more wedding stuff."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously.
That's like Walmart saying,
Nobody's allowed inside
with a barbed-wire tattoo."
[ Laughter ]
That's like a Motel 6 saying,
"Look, we don't want
anyone in here with bedbugs,
okay?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but schools
and college football are fine.
It's Bob and Doreen coming home
from Toronto that's the problem.
[ Laughter ]
And this is interesting.
It's only August, but check out
what's already
showing up in stores.
-We're still in summer,
but Halloween candy displays
have arrived even earlier
this year.
-Why do we even need
Halloween this year?
Every day, we're walking around
in a mask, completely terrified.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the good news is,
now you can walk in
to any pharmacy and get
Halloween candy.
The bad news is,
still no Clorox wipes.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, CVS employees are
carrying Christmas trees like,
"You guys still talking about
Halloween?"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this -- a new study
shows that using mouthwash
could reduce the risk
of contracting coronavirus.
Study might be good news,
although now it feels like
we're one press conference away
from Trump telling us
to inject Scope.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
this is pretty crazy.
A professional stuntman decided
to propose to his girlfriend
after lighting himself on fire.
Take a look at this thing.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
And just to mess with him,
she was like,
"Mm, let me think about it
for a sec."
[ Laughter ]
I'm kidding.
She said yes,
and then things took a turn when
he jumped up and hugged her.
[ Laughter ]
No, no, it was cute right up
until she ran off
with the fireman
who saved that guy's life.